hey it's stephanie and welcome to the  google cloud tech  youtube channel have you ever wondered  how machine learning can make you a  better athlete  or how a data center looks and works  curious about how to speed up your app  development  need to stay up to date with google  cloud's latest updates and product  launches  if the answer is yes to any of these  questions  you've come to the right place whether  you are a seasoned engineer  or just starting out on your developer  journey every day  our team of cloud experts release new  videos to  educate inspire and inform developers of  all skill sets and experiences  subscribe to the channel today and join  our community to learn what the cloud  can do for you